I guess I'm supposed to mine the next
block now so this is Joseph Twitter who
is an associate professor at EU wide and
also work cited interchain and he will
be talking about basically the tender
mint so I will talk about tender means
so I'm here for the interchange
foundation and actually we are going to
it's a transition phase soon the
recession development will be called
informal systems we're going we're going
to spin out but for now it's interchange
foundation I wanted to choose a little
bit what we are doing and who we are so
to researchers currently accept me it's
a work with me is ego Knopf who's an
expert in other computed verification
and charka Milosevic who is expertise
with algorithms and for servants and so
we have to be a Swiss non-profit
foundation and we support research
development of secure and scalable
decentralized applications and currently
we're focusing in this is why I'm here
on cosmos Network and tender means that
the question of course what does this
words mean so let's start with with
cosmos so cosmos is our vision of
decentralized networks of independent
blockchains so we don't believe that
there should be just survivor in these
competitions of talk chain and then
everyone should run their pieces on them
our view is that every community should
have their their own block change their
loops of leaf in this in the cosmos
ecosystem and they should communicate
with each other via interpreter
communication protocol so it's a little
bit like like like villages cities and
countries so you know each pop chain is
like a city and most of the business
coexist in the city and sometimes you
have to communicate with another city
and then sort of discos
we are this inter blockchain
communication protocol
and so as I said what it's said here
it's that should be like tender mint by
this we mean that a civil to state
machine replication in the in the
classic sense the indecent in fault
tolerance so it's a strong tonality this
is the also they're sort of the
assumption that lies behind behind IVC
and so tenement is this is containers
algorithm that ran to this the core of
the system it is Byzantine folder and
state machine replication and it's a
modern implementation of classic ideas
here it says P P of T and TLS so we say
P of T because more people know it but
the algorithm is closer to the torrent
or my consensus algorithm and if you
know the paper and you should definitely
read the paper
it's the authenticated Byzantine case
and this algorithm it's basically the
blueprint for what we are doing
I say it's modern because it's designed
to run on a wide area network with big
numbers of nodes which requires us that
the communication is to because you
paste in order to be to be a fish
and everything is open source you can
find all the code online and which is
something which is sometimes the best
thing to me is that actually also our
technical discussions are online so we
have to development sessions every week
they are recorded and they are put on
YouTube and then you can see how we say
crazy stuff sometimes so it's a you can
follow all our discussions there and all
our developments and since this is here
a consensus seminar I have tripped one
slide on on consensus and that is it so
this is sort of the idea of tenement
contenders and this is also why I said
it goes to TLS because you don't have
sort of this notion of you know few
change and then broadcast so what what
you have you have if you know someone
literally the proposal so value then
it's checked or validity and it's pre
volted then you wait for three votes
then depending on how many pre votes we
get you have pre commits and then
depending on what's happened either if
the contest is not so not successful we
got a new round round which means we're
going to pick a new leader or we're
going to commit which means we have to
we have generated a new a new block and
we go to the next hide and end to this
again
let me have this notion of rotating
coordinator is sort of part of our idea
to fairness so we want that everyone who
participates in the protocol has to
change to actively propose propose to
values and their influence on what is
going to happen and therefore we have
these these rotating rotating
coordinators which is weighted over the
voting powers
and actually the system is much more
complicated than typical figures to see
you know for processes this is a sketch
of how the different roles that we have
in tandem in so what we have we have
validators so many deeds are the notes
typically using consensus algorithm
should actually participate that
generate new messages the design the
design values and all our notes here are
full notes they participate in the in
the gossiping and they also total follow
the state machine so they receive the
messages when they have received 2/3 of
certain messages into the
state-transition but if they are not
validators they're not going to generate
messages in the sense that they don't
sign the tone sign messages the reason
why we have here these meditators here
sort of hidden behind the Sentry notes
is because at the end of the tastes
super complicated to be a validator
because what you have you need to have
your private key on in a computer that
is online and it's sort of therefore
attackable and sort of one of the ideas
is that abilities actually are not
talking directly to the outside world
but the hide behind is is essentially
notes also it's not their IP addresses
that are known to the to the protocols
it's just the public keys so this is
part of the of the security setup that
me
yeah the guy and can then talk to two
and then from an architecture viewpoint
the important feature of tenement is
that we have this application blockchain
interface so our view is that every
application should run their own
blockchain in the idea of being being a
decentralized but then of course I will
not say every application I have a very
vague view of application in the sense
it also a virtual machine can be an
application and actually they are
several pros our projects that implement
different virtual machines on top of
tandem in so there's a virtual machine
for serial for a move for part for both
um I keep forgetting I think a core ik
so they are headphone so there are we
are open there many projects that build
on top
and that sort of - to conclude this this
overview of the past I want to keep the
the historical background so check one
wrote the white paper contains us
without mining to have to say two year
about to fullfil steak and then each
compartment in his master thesis were
convinced Enderman contains the
algorithm then the idea of the cosmos
network comes from this 2916 white paper
and then in 2018 Shaka Malaysia which
contributed to this he found some some
lifeless sparks in the in the in the in
the thesis paper even and so they fix
them here in this in this sort of the
historical historical background of the
pandemic project it's quite clear
questions
then they go on so to give some idea
what we are like to keep something what
we are currently doing and one of the
projects that we are working on right
now is the light client which is a very
modern term actually what in all
nineties language it's basically it's
basically a read so we have here this
view of the of the tenement blockchain
where you have here these nodes that
that run the the application and we want
to have that you know kinds from time to
time
no connect and figure and want to take a
block and it should be light in the
sense that they should not be forced to
do all the computations if they sleep
for for a day in compact we do not want
if they won't just want to see the most
recent block we don't want them that
they have to follow all the blocks that
have been generated it's the problem so
the security model that we that lies
beyond Oslo in our solution is everybody
data has some built in power the quality
to set can potentially change at the end
of every block so in the consensus the
validators also decide who's going to be
debilitated for the next containers
instance and but this villager said
change is controlled by the application
which also means it can totally change
where there are no assumptions on this
change in the in the containers little
bit
and because we have this proof of stake
and if you want to get the stake out you
have to wait some time in order to that
we can check whether you paved nicely we
have this assumption that if a block is
committed at time T then the set of the
next meditators two thirds of them must
be correct until t plus TP is
distrusting period which is imposed by
the by the unbounding period so it'll be
complicated let's see a figure so it's
zoom here we have here the time X is T
at this time instants here we have a
block generated here this here is a
depiction of the validator said there
are might be some faulty ones here and
timber some correct ones here and the
assumption is that during this drastic
period these guys in here behave
correctly and at most this guy here we
have 40 and if at some later point in
time
another block is generated and the new
valid and status code is elected labor
might look like this so you have here
some correct tires again some faulty
guys and this for this plastic period
this holds its although somehow means
that in this of men we have this
overlapping here and they are typically
very long because blocks are generated
every five to six seconds and this
drastic period in the current blockchain
is is three weeks when we have this
overlapping this generates restrictions
about who can be correct and and two can
be faulty
now of course the problem nor the
taillight current phases is the
following so for example I don't know a
block was was generated we I don't know
at this point here and then it goes to
sleep for a week it comes here it is a
new validator set it gets a block with
stability to say can it trust this new
block or not and that's the problem that
we have
so I'm principle what is quite easy to
observe so if the light kind sees this
block here it goes to sleep and wakes up
here there's nothing it can just no
trust it is left the last information it
had was this one this information is
outdated and it cannot do anything so at
this point the only thing you can do is
you go to your favorite newspaper dealer
and ask him can you give me a new
trustee talar
that I can use to get to get new states
but if the light kind is online every
other day or say every M once every week
we want to ensure that with the trust to
the test by knowing that this header
here was correctly generated that it
could be that it can verify the set up
possibly without checking too many
haters here in between that's the
problem here you're looking at the
problem is you have to track validator
changes it's said it's a read but we
cannot do the classic read that you
could do when you had a static
membership in in state machine
replication in the old days you asked
just everyone who participates give me
the current state you wait until you
receive F plus one authentic answers in
no one correct guy was among them and
you're happy now you don't even know who
to ask because the ability to chase it
that can change all the time so the
security of this slight kind depends of
the proof of stake timing assumption as
I said so we have to use this time in
order to establish the trust and of
course that eventually so this is not a
security but the liveness eventually
actually we can connect to a correct
node to give us to give us blows
so how does it work well the light
client is initialized with the trusty
Teta h1 which is sort of the route for
its trust it downloads this new
headlight interested in verifying and it
tries to verify the new header based on
information that is in H 1 and H of this
of this block and then once it has
verified nu H 2 it has enough
information to get to extract all the
information from the application as
merpeople
so here's just one sketch one part of
the after of the header verification
just to give you an idea what we are
doing so that function here has an old
data which each one which is trusted and
the new header h2 first we check that
the old header isn't expired if the
Altera expired we have to say we cannot
give you any trust on h2 then we compute
the voting power that was there in the
old header then here we check that the
header h2 is currently signed so this is
just the condition about the well-formed
s of the header h2 and then this year is
the interesting check here we check
basically that the new header h2 is
signed by at least one process that is
correct
that became to be sure to be correct by
the drastic period assumption so here we
have this one-third so intuitively it's
sort of the intersection in the
meditators ensures that one-third more
than one-third of the old meditators are
still around then when we can do this
check if this check fails
it doesn't mean that this is a header
here it's forged it might just be the
case that between h1 and h2 too many
changes in the validator set happen but
we don't do it to some bisecting so we
asked for some header in between in
order to to generate this trust
dimension we currently doing and
actually I haven't talked at all about
the title of of the talk which was about
strengthening in disputed systems and I
want to talk a little bit about actually
the main project that I'm involved in
and this is called we wanted to
verification driven design so I come
from academia and there we have this
ivory tower idea what how systems are
designed right we have an algorithmic
idea we are going to write them in a
domain-specific language we can actually
then do some automated verification even
on that if you are happy right then from
this we can synthesize the code nicely
automatically to automate verification
and to get the system and correct by
construction everything works fine I am
a scientist
yeah but of course it's all wrong now so
we don't have this language we have to
decoded paste we have many computational
models we have heard words like Mik
synchrony eventual synchrony part of
synchrony all this is not not illusions
in English at best we don't have formal
semantics of them
I know the other side on the
verification side everything is
complicated we have unbounded state
spaces we have parameter sphere false so
I tend we're going to have they going to
have box and this system in this problem
is real there are parks in in systems
even if you know he reviewed papers we
understand that no things happen so
there are some sub goals one thing quite
hard to follow in the slides you know
and then we have some part in the in the
system here or some small omission if
I'm a specification and at some point
you don't actually have teacher election
so his post on the problem is both of
course on the on the application side
and Dante on the implementation side and
what we try to do is we want to to
eliminate that we want to have a more
rigorous approach to the to engineering
of systems so the first point we're
going to to start with pottsy style
specs i like to say so with problem
statement assumptions some solutions and
some arguments widely occurring in the
important point from years that these
specifications they should be acceptable
both for us in the verification side on
the academic side and for the engineers
if you look at specifications that are
written by engineers they talk about
data structures they talk about api's
but you will not find a lightness
specification of the of the thing in
there for example okay so you need
something to sort of spain this both
words then what do you want to do we
want to write formal specifications in
tll does this sort of should make the
english formal and if the english is not
formal enough fix the english at some
point the current implementation of this
protocol in rust and as first step
toward correctness we are going to test
implementation against ela specs and
vice versa and finally we're going to to
automated verification of the of the
Chile specs and in system effect we are
wanted to automate it verification we
don't want to spend five people six
months in writing machine checkable
proof this is not going to scale in our
world where the protocols are changing
or changing all the time we want methods
that you have a bigger discreet
Automation and actually the light kind
that was presented this sort of our
first pilot project really really be
doing it and just to convince you that
I'm not totally crazy about what I'm
gaming here I want to do some some some
recent results ahead on automated
verification which I think we made some
nice progress so the first result I want
to talk is verification of protocols and
what we developed in the last together
with eager you saw his pictures under a
second to the picture the second slide
is the piece of teen model checker so
the problem that we are taking on the
high level is paralyzed model checking
so when I was in undergrad most taking
meant I would ride my protocol for some
old checker fix the parameter in and to
exhaustive state space exploration and
then it would give me counter examples
or not but then if I would write a paper
for these Capote I would write proofs
for n right which is an arbitrary game
so what we want to do is imperative a to
application we want to have a
description of the system check against
temporal formulas but keep n is a
parameter we don't want to fix it
and the algorithms we looked at are very
close to the algorithms we have
discussed here the last week here is a
standard example rather broadcast which
may come in tweak what you find here is
threshold guards it's the major point
this is also you know we have discussed
forums and all that this is sort of the
cones representation how to check with
our in our forums intersect and you have
these recipients conditions on the
system and with what this then this
gives you actually in parameterize
clarification is that you want have a
system of n processes there's an
assumption about the number of faults
and F are actually Fault in Iran and you
want to check whether for all values NT
and they if that satisfies for example
this famous n is greater than 3 T the
parallel composition of n minus F
correct processes and these processes
are also parameterize because energy
showed up in the code with F false
satisfies our safety safety and likeness
properties
in general these problems are
undecidable but what we could do is we
could for this threshold cardio danger
the algorithms define automata for which
we actually have nice results and we can
automatically for all for the parametric
case check as you know a number of of
disability rhythms from literature and
last week in the freedom workshop at
disk
Misaka moley presented his own work he's
our first user and he used the Byzantine
model checker to check the broadcast of
the red-bellied blockchain so that's
quite quite exciting and sort of the
theoretical underpinning behind just to
give you sort of the idea be use permit
model checking which basically means
what we can do we can take execution of
a fixed finite length against the
specification but of course what we want
to do is we want to check all executions
the big question is whether there is an
if it only between them actually what we
have done in the last year's we have
shown that for these threshold cally at
algorithms we can make this part more
chicken complete for safety and like
this it sort of the on the on the
protocol side so what's the verification
of implementation and of code I've
worked together with Josiah cargo from
from India in Paris and what we did here
we dig up some old literature and saw
really I call the communication closure
but there is also a very nice paper by a
live very caustic concept stratified
decomposition so what's the idea of
communication culture communication
coercion basically means is that we have
programs that locally go through a
sequence of of blocks of the code and
for example the second block of this
process here only communicate with the
second block of this code here so if
they are structured in a way that one
blocks only comma indicates with the
same block of now the process this is a
communication closed here the first
block sends a message to this to the
second block is not communication goes
so we use these notions
and if you think back up but also some
algorithms we have talked about this
week for example a few change typically
you have a little active phase and you
have a broadcast phase and the lead
election messages are not going to
interfere with the broadcast and the
broadcast are not going to interfere
with the little action ok so here you
have a decomposition of these algorithms
and they're not interfering but of
course there is yes also always a
trivial decomposition right you can
always say the whole program is one
layer and everything is fine the
question is which is a good layer of
decomposition and the nicest layer is of
course if you have message chained one
which corresponds in our nice view of
distributed computing to the notion of
around and if you have notions of the
round from a verification viewpoint it's
super exciting right you just have told
you don't have interleavings you tend to
have to deal with fixed like who does
the first step or something
you just talk about what message you're
sending around which messages are
received in the round which also means
you don't have to think about message
buffers if you want to reason about the
asynchronous system and they do this in
an asynchronous environment so if you
have always to carry around invariants
about all the message purpose if you
don't like doing this case you can
reason about the rounds in isolation and
you get much simpler proof arguments
so what we've done in that work we our
answer we asked to question which
protocols the communication ghost and
how can we compute R and D composition
so we have foreign automatic methods
very annotated code that can identify
automatically communication goes to a
synchronous protocols once we have them
we're going to rewrite them
automatically into synchronous protocols
and then to specification on the
synchronous problem idea here so here
you have some schema of this algorithm
I've shown you before and then you sort
of have to understand we are in the code
round around but round boundaries and
then you're doing this writing in the in
the synchronous code once you have a
synchronous code and of course it proof
that the semantics are the same to the
producing distinguishable executions
once you have done that you can pick one
of the verification methods for
synchronous algorithms that have been
developed in the last year centers which
interests in the verification will give
artists with evidence so what we have
done we have taken some algorithms and
call the time in C basically and is that
this invariant statistic to the
synchronous codes so we have written
them and it's a verification and we used
deductive verification in piecing so to
not keep your wave much longer from from
from lunch I talked to you a little bit
about what is our idea about cosmos and
antenna mean what we are currently doing
for the light line and for me the
interesting thing is that what we want
to do in the next in the next month is
really to sort of reimplemented
attainment in rust into this innovated
we have better trust in the correctness
of the systems and the correctness of
the protocols that's all thanks
there's a lot of good now above this in
enhance again they have a language how
to write things run background and
Melissa give has this EPR sister ERP
system proof and they claim that they
don't have appreciate that everything
that could be round can be round by
round can be translated to the EPA to
the a POV p.m. I don't ok over there and
then they have an automated to prove to
it once you put it in this logic so III
expected he PR to come somewhere here
but it didn't it's not yeah because it's
a little bit of different approach still
I didn't know that they work on on on
rewriting into synchronous rounds so
about to work but the hint see a group
searches are actually was in that group
and last we created workshop as I said
in in in in Budapest and there was a
talk by the head singer group that
worked on that and this rewriting into
synchronous rounds is currently a hot
topic enter several groups doing that
they understood they ain't the problem
to reason about each bit systems is to
handle partial orders because it's
what's going on and instead of reasoning
about sort of all the executions you
just want to pick one execution which
was presented possibly big set of
execution is impartial order and it is
what's going on this is the point that
with the idea of stratified
decomposition we sort of say ok the
moment this is actually the algorithm
isn't round semantically we can
understand how to do that and while this
was in 87 I could idea to write
mathematical proofs and it's very nice
it here what we try to do is we want to
use it for automated reasoning and this
is more recent this is going on right
now
let's thank the speaker and you can take
the rest of the questions offline
[Applause]